what's happening you bad [__]
it's thursday february 4th
the joint is brought to you by relief
band
do you know that a third of americans
regularly suffer
from nausea listen after this surgery
those pills got me nauseous as [__] i
got relief banned i put it on
it's on me every day since i've had the
surgery
it helps with the recuperation and this
is why
i love it relief band is the number one
fda cleared anti-nausea wristband
that has been clinically proven to
relieve
and prevent nausea and vomiting
the product is 100 percent drug free so
it doesn't make you drowsy
and has zero side effects how do i know
because i've been using it for the last
four weeks this kind of thing is used
only
and available in hospital patients but
now
it's available for everybody relief band
is the only over-the-counter wearable
band
that has been used in hospitals and
oncology clinics
to treat nausea and vomiting like i said
i've had it on for the last four weeks
those pain pills make me nauseous
whether it's the codeine the oxycodone
whatever it is
if i don't have my wristband on and i go
to pt
and i'm in the back seat i get carsick
if i have my band on boom i'm brand new
i'm telling you this from experience
relief band
works ensure nausea is never the reason
to miss out on life's important moments
right now
relief band has an exclusive offer just
for uncle joey's joint
people my family you guys are family
if you go to reliefband.com
releaseband.com and use promo code joey
you'll receive 20 off plus free shipping
and a no questions asked 30 day money
back guarantee did you hear what i said
if you go to reliefband.com right now
you use promo code joey
you're going to get 20 off plus free
shipping
and a no question 30 day money back
guarantee
that's what i'm talking about so head
over to relief band
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use promo code joey
to receive 20 off and get relief from
that nausea you're gonna be
you're gonna you're gonna tweet me joey
thank you thank you for it
for referring me to relief band now from
the heart of jersey
i'm bringing you draftkings and if
there's a weekend for draftkings
it's this weekend why joey what's going
on
i've been living under a [__] rock
well let me tell you [__]
it's the 55th super bowl this sunday
buccaneers versus the chiefs it's going
down in [__] tampa
they're letting people in they don't
give a [__] about
covert they don't give a [__] about
nothing this game deserves a big prize
all right
not just some [__] trophy that some
old guy gives you with bad breath
to finish off the football season
draftking sportsbook
america's top-rated sportsbook app is
giving you
all you players a no-brainer offer are
you ready for this
to celebrate the football finale
draftking sportsbook
is doubling your money if the touchdown
is scored
in the big game what are you talking
about joey a single touchdown
just a touchdown a touchdown you win
money
that's right all it takes is one
touchdown
to be scored sunday night and boom your
money's doubled
it's a no [__] brainer a single
touchdown
and you double your [__] doe who's
better than you
if you've been waiting on the sidelines
all [__] year
listen this is the last [__] train
out of [__] auschwitz
it's time to lay your [__] money down
that's it enough with the [__]
you cheap [__] you want to make a
little cash
this is the [__] weekend all right
and don't forget draftkings big game
prediction challenge
with up to 55 million dollars in total
prizes up for grabs
and instant prizes for everybody who
enters the contest
listen when it comes to [__] having
fun draftkings is number one
they're fun as hell i've been
discovering them lately and i love it
tonight you got some games it starts
tonight tonight i think you got like uh
denver against the lakers look at that
line
and you got portland against philly take
a look at that line
draftkings is before you it starts
tonight okay draftkings has paid out
over seven
billion dollars to its players since
so they know a thing or two about big
pay days so this weekend
it's your big [__] payday download
the draftking sportsbook app
now today use promo code joey to get a
shot
at doubling your money if a touchdown is
scored on sunday's game
how easy is that that's promo code joey
to get a shot
at dublin you get us during sunday night
season finale
only at draftking sportsbook the best
sports book in the [__] world you
understand me and here's the part the
lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 take your [__] kazoo
and shove it up your ass you're not
allowed in here new jersey
indiana colorado only restrictions do
apply
see draftkings.com prediction dash
challenge dfs for details now
if you got a gambling problem you gotta
take care of it
that's the good thing about draftkings
they don't let your bet over your head
but if you got a problem get the [__]
out of here
go get help you got 1-800 gambler
or an indiana 1-809 with it or in
colorado 1-800
but if you ain't got no problems and
you're ready to [__] rock and roll
this is the weekend to start go to
draftkings right now
download the draftking sportsbook app
use promo code joey i'm even lighting a
candle for you for tonight
so go bet the [__] lakers
against the nuggets there you go candles
lit i love you [__]
look who it
uncle joey's is
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here
thursday february 4th i'm sorry about
the podcast this week
because of the snow and [__] i didn't
want mike driving around and all that
[__]
plus thursday's a great day to release a
podcast nobody misses out nothing
friday that's a [__] up day we got
about a [__] foot of snow up here
my daughter was [__] ecstatic i went
out there yeah
i can't do dick if i fall i [__] go
back to the hospital so i was out there
walking around and stuff
[__] snow was beautiful i forgot how
much i missed it man
[__] beautiful there's parts of new
jersey where they got 34 [__] inches
of snow
i mean it was just [__] beautiful um
they took a sleigh riding yesterday
she went over there with jimmy
florentine's son and a bunch of other
kids and my wife went down the hill
our neighbor frank went down a hill
but they had a great time and that's all
that mattered it wasn't that [__]
cold nobody was dying
it was just a regular winter [__]
snowstorm they haven't had this much
snow and i don't know how many [__]
years
but it was great i got to tell you
something while reminding me about snow
real quick
the cop that i turned myself into that
pulled the gun on me when i [__]
kidnapped bella
became my friend on facebook so how's
that for you [__]
i sent them a note my friend of them
james colar
great guy he was involved in the
jonbenet murders
he was one of the investigators in the
john bernay murders
i saw him on cbs one day and i sent him
a [__] you see the type of guy i am
i saw him doing a john bernay thing and
i sent i
looked him up on facebook i sent him a
[__] email on facebook
he never returned it back to me i was
like what the [__] you know
then i sent him a really nice when i
told him that he arrested me
that [__] uh you know i'm a comic now
i've done well for myself i turned my
life around
and he friended me and he sent me a nice
note how's that after 37 [__] years
who's better than you [__] that's
what's being called relentless right
there
now the other cop that arrested me he
could burn in hell i don't give a [__]
about him
but jimmy colar was a good [__] cop
but anyway today we're going to cover
one of the spectrums
of the mind of joey diaz and that's
addiction and one of the addictions
one of the parts of addiction that i
consider an addiction that
people wouldn't consider an addiction
it was when i was a kleptomaniac i was a
professional
[__] kleptomaniac it's embarrassing
to even talk about
i've had listen i've gone through the
whole spectrum of problems as a kid
from five to seven i was like a
professional i was like a semi-pro
pyromaniac
i could light fires anywhere i knew how
to control oxygen
you know i did the boy scouts for like
two days
i just knew different things i knew
where to set a fire how the wind would
blow i mean it was [__] crazy
and then one day i almost burned down a
building and i stopped being a [__]
pyromaniac
nobody deserves to [__] i think i
burned myself at the same time
i said this pyro [__] ain't for me as a
kid
i gotta be honest with you i was such a
catholic i wouldn't think of [__]
clipping anything
it wasn't till i got out of catholic
school that i started clipping bicycles
and stuff like that
and i didn't look at them as clipping
them it wasn't me that was actually
getting on the bike and riding the bike
and the kid's like hey come back
no that wasn't me i don't want you to
think i was that type of person
i was involved in daily operations maybe
investing in paint selling the bike from
whatever i'm a salesman not a [__]
you know
but the klepto thing started after my
mother died you know
once everything broke down in my life i
became a [__] professional klepto i
mean i i just
had a [__] steal it i had a [__]
steal
[__] and it went on for years it was a
disease i fought
for [__] years the only problem is
there's no kleptoes anonymous
there's nothing for the [__] klepto
the klepto just lays there
if you're an alky they got a problem for
you if you suck 20 dicks in one year
they got a
[__] meeting for you they got a
meeting for everything
but if you're a klepto they got no
meetings for klepto's [__] anonymous
so it's tough to tell these [__]
stories or to be honest about them
because
and it's just the truth i'm just trying
to this is one of the [__] things
of the circle addiction addiction
part of an addiction is uh something
stupid that you're doing
and i highly like i was robbing drug
dealers and i was
robbing a jewelry store that's [__]
one thing
that's called burglary that's a complete
[__] different thing
but when you got to take a [__] like
you know i would have to steal a lighter
like [__] like that like i would do dumb
[__]
you know i was just talking to somebody
maybe a month ago or something i go does
that person still work with you
it was longer than that because it had
to be before the pandemic
and they said that that person didn't
work with them no more
because the shirts always came too short
every night after a show even though he
sold 100
shirts the money would always be missing
for two [__] shirts
that was me you know what i'm saying
like
now he's got four guys helping him he's
got to sit there every night like a
[__] swami
and see who's got enough balls to steal
two
you know 22 shirts from every [__]
night
and i laughed because that was me in my
mind
and you're in the klepto's mind he
always has to get over
you know even if they give you six
shrimp you gotta take seven
you know what i'm saying nothing is
[__] good enough i remember
pulling up to the [__] comedy store
one day
in 1999 maybe
to get a check pulling up there and
seeing
10 cases of booze outside
you know the liquor guy had left off but
they weren't inside
and me having to fight the [__] urge
to steal all 10 of those because i knew
it was easy money
all you got to do is put them in the
trunk of your car and go to a
liquor store and give them a price go to
their shelves
see what they charge for it go to the
car turn
you know give them a case for half price
and they'll [__]
buy all eight of them but i knew i was
smart enough that that was my place of
business at the time
i had already matured i was 30 years old
i didn't want to [__] get thrown out
of the comedy store
for stealing booze but that's how long
it was still in my blood i just
want to let you guys know but the peak
of it
was when i was 20 [__] years old you
know what made me think about this whole
thing
was this [__] snow the other day i
was outside when it first started
snoring i was watching my daughter
with the neighbors kids going up and
down
and i saw when she came up she left
footsteps
and i thought about this [__] story
that is just mind-boggling
that i did knowing you know when i moved
to colorado
by the time i got to colorado i was
already damaged goods let's not get
uh i will tell you one thing about when
i first went to colorado in 83
i did i wasn't the junkie i ended up
becoming i still had everything under
control believe it or not
i had the reefer under control the
alcohol was very minimal
i was playing a role
so i was not doing coke in public
i think from july
from april of 83
to february of 84.
if i tell you i snorted twice a month
that was in those days come on guys i i
would i ended up doing coke seven nights
a week
so i wasn't really the drugs were still
under check
i had taken some valiums i had done
heroin at that age
but up there when i was living a snow
mass between
april of 83 and february of 84
my world was basically reefer it was
92 percent reefer i think i took a
quaalude
maybe two or three times to get quality
on halloween thank god
because we were dressed as abortions if
we would have gone up to the [__]
parade they would have [__]
killed us uh i took a quail it on thanks
guys swear to god
me and my buddies my roommate dressed up
like abortions
we put hangers around our neck and we
put long underwear on
and we were watching monday night
football we ate a quaalude
we're like we'll wait till the quaalude
hits and then we'll go to [__]
monday night madness up there for
halloween
but aspen has like a more crawl like
boulder
boulder and aspen are both known for
their halloweens
and [__] next thing you know we wake
up it's four in the morning
it's tuesday man he's laying there with
a hanger around his [__] neck
unfucking believable so then [__]
thanksgiving i ate a quaalude and i
think new year's eve maybe i had a quail
my drug problem was on the check so
there was no reason for me to act
how i was acting i got
you know every month in college it was
funny because one time joe went to
boulder and he
i called him when he was there and i go
what do you think about [__]
all i can think about is you [__]
you know living here and it's like a
candy store for you it's like a kid in
the [__] candy store
i go please you should have seen
snowmass in 83
and he was exactly right i was like a
kid in a candy store
i'd come from an area where everything
is locked up
in north bergen new jersey everything's
locked up your car
you [__] lock up your bike you you
put two locks
on your shed you put [__] titanium
explosives
you know and then you're out in colorado
and people leave
their car windows open their cars open
they have ski closets and they live skis
in there and you can just take the skis
and sell them secondhand
i mean the trust value was [__]
phenomenal and for a knucklehead like me
i just took it you know i was a [__]
knucklehead why do you think
i mean my two options when i went to
move were either
colorado or new jersey you know i didn't
go back to colorado
because of the embarrassment i have
towards that state
towards those mountains those mountains
were beautiful i always wanted to go to
colorado ever since i was a kid
and i'd watch like the news or they show
you like this show's coming on tonight
nine o'clock pacific
10 o'clock mountain i'm like mountain
who lives on a [__] mountain i want
to go see that [__] mountain so
i ended up going out there and i ended
up acting like a [__] [__]
ended up doing time ended up getting
divorced so i don't deserve colorado
that's god's country
but till this day i still feel that
strongly that i like [__] on colorado i
was like a [__] [__]
it wasn't a place for me to act that way
but at that time i didn't know any
better i was just a young
stupid kid who had lost his mother and
thought the world owed him something
that's what i thought
so if you weren't going to give it to me
i'm going to [__] take it and that's
not the right [__] attitude to have
at that age
but and i had to actually work
on my klepto skills like i actually had
to wake up you know how i write my goals
today
i used to have to wake up and go like
today i'm not going to [__] steal
and i didn't know about writing it down
or anything like that i would just say
it to myself in the shower like
today i'm not gonna [__] steal like i
would
you know i i told you the story when i
got the job at the [__]
masbach hardware and i went the guy told
me to go upstairs to eat lunch
and i went upstairs to eat lunch and i
wanted to i thought the lunches were
for free and i opened up the cabinet and
there's [__] a sandwich in there with
like milk or something
i ate the whole [__] thing i don't
even know what the [__] it was i just
told the story on the church
and time to say this big black guy comes
in he's like somebody stole my
[__] lunch
and he ripped the [__] thing off the
thing like i did [__] like that
not because i was a douchebag just i
didn't know better
but by the time i got the [__]
snowmass i [__] knew better
and i was just dog i was taking
everything
everything but when i tell you that i
would have to [__]
tell myself like i'm not stealing
nothing today i'm not stealing
like like all right joey give us an
example
when i work for chip mason chip chills
and masonry
right i would always take home two bags
of concrete
and sell them just just just you know
knucklehead [__]
at time i'd go get two bags of concrete
and put them on and put my [__]
winter jacket over it
or whatever i had in the back of the
truck and once i would have like ten
bags i'd go up to the job site and sell
them for [__] like thirty dollars
like [__] like that like i was just a
[__] stupid klepto you know what i'm
saying like
entertaining like it was entertaining
and i did [__]
but then i would control myself but then
i was like oh let me have a cocktail
this is when it got really creepy this
is when the kleptoism got really
creepy when i would have a cocktail
i would have i would drink southern
comfort and orange juice those days
the most disgusting [__] in the world
you could drink
who the [__] drink southern comforter
orange juice
i would drink two of them and get [__]
up and then i'd have to steal something
you have no idea how many things i stole
do you remember him
like the next day oh yeah like there was
this dude that had a heart out for me
i don't know why he didn't like me a
snowmass i didn't like him too much
either
he had like a hedge of white privilege
he was very
white privileged and he owned like a
sandwich shop
and one day i went in there and he gave
me a [__] hard time
the second time i went today he gave me
like a hard time like i you know ham and
cheese
what type of cheese i don't have to ask
you again like he was like a half a
tough guy
i wasn't a tough guy so i said you know
whatever
he made a gate a great three cheese
sandwich i remember that they made great
three cheese sandwiches
well one september i'm walking around up
there and a friend of mine actually
worked for him i became friends with him
after spending time up there and i went
up there to see if my friend was i think
he sold weed i don't i don't [__]
know
and i went around the back and sure
enough the door was open
and i [__] went in and i just robbed
everything
there was a bank bag right on top of the
thing i just took it i think it was like
1800 bucks
i went up to aspen i bought a stereo
speakers i bought the first madonna
album
i thought i bought the first deal album
holy diver
you know i did [__] like that i hated
that guy that owned that business
plus he was a musician he was a conga
player at night
at a different bar the bar that was next
to the to john denver's
so one night i told my buddy i go carl
the dude who punched [__] shotgun
doug's friend
and knocked him out carl was an animal
by that time i knew carl hall
was all the way in so me and carl are at
this bar
i worked at the tower restaurant that
was john denver's restaurant i was a
dishwasher
and i had the night off so i said let me
go [__] it up a car a little bit
so there was a bar next to the diner the
tower
restaurant i don't know what the [__]
the name of the bar was
so call didn't like that dude either
carl did not like that [__] dude who
played the congress
and owned the [__] sandwich shop
car got [__] up one night and i walk
in there and i get a [__]
whatever a [__] jack dan whatever the
[__]
whatever the [__] what was i drinking
all right i don't know
southern comforter orange juice i got
two of me
lit me already right like christmas eve
i swear to god christmas eve
1983. i go in there
it's maybe six people call
a guy about a guitar like playing like a
classical guitar
and the guy that owns the restaurant
playing the bongos
i take a look at carl i go look at that
[__] hump
that [__] sack of [__] i can't stand
them carl looks at me he's a redneck
he's like
i don't like him myself i said he goes
watch this and he went and he got a
[__] beer and he shook it up
he shook it up he shook it up he shook
it up and he walked over to the guy
and he just unloaded the beer and the
conga play his face
and he got up and he's like i'll [__]
kill you and carl goes come on i'll see
you outside tough guy
carl ran outside the guy chased him i
got up and picked up the guy's conga
and ran out the back door
[Music]
and i sold it to my neighbor for the
small 25 that night you know what i'm
saying
that's how we ran those days doug that
guy looked for that conga
for [__] months he couldn't find that
[__] conga
i forgot all about that story you see
what i'm saying i got plenty of stories
you guys thought i ran out of them
i just had a dig this is what happens
when you write a book you think about
all that [__]
because i've been making notes on little
things now that i'm writing
every time i see something i make a
little note and i go i gotta lay this
dog that night was tremendous that dude
looked for that conga drum for [__]
years
listen i left in february of 84.
i came back in october november of 86
and carl hall pulled me over one night
he goes
do you know that dude is still looking
for that conga drum
i had forgotten all about the conga drum
we had died
he had even at one point put like a help
wanted sign like a
a sign all around snowmass village and
aspen
looking for that specific conga the guy
saw that there was a conga specialist
he was a real conga player this guy was
a [__]
mozambique this [__] guy sold it to
who really knew about the conga he
wasn't
it was a worth a lot of con it was a lot
of it it wasn't like an
lp lp was the kong of choice when i was
growing up that was the brand
but this was like a [__] high he had
like custom made somewhere
i stole the man's conga how [__]
crazy
am i so it's funny because
that was who i was back then and
i tamed it i tamed it for a long time
and then i couldn't tame it anymore like
i tried to put in a capsule for a long
time
you know the summer of 84
83 i spent my whole summer shooting
that's all i did saturdays and sundays
shooting learning how to make bombs how
to make tripwires
you know this guy was training me to be
a [__] masochist
like he was just training me to do some
crazy things and i loved
i loved it i wanted to be that person
you know i don't want to be that person
today
but that's what i was training to be he
was teaching me how to shoot with a
scope
i mean this guy was teaching me how to
do some crazy [__] stuff you know
once i moved to snowmass village it was
harder for me to see fred
you know i would see him instead of four
times
a month on the weekends i would see him
just like
you know once i started taking classes
and
[__] working for the electrician the
whole thing i wouldn't see them that
much you know i was working saturday so
i couldn't go shoot that much
that's when my kleptoism
got higher now i wouldn't klepto from
people that i knew
i would just klepto and klepto when i
say klepto
i mean the complete [__] package i
was just a [__] nutcase
i mean you know everything had a
question mark to me like i would
walk past an eyeglass place and say to
myself i wonder if they got 50 000
in the [__] safe and i would convince
myself
that they had 50 that was like the most
[__] thing i ever did in my life
i would convince myself that there was
fifty thousand dollars in there
then i would break in there and then be
[__] with gods in the [__] safe
and i get pissed off of myself let me
tell you something you know that a lot
of you watch those cop videos
and see uh amateurs like you know
[__] crooks that make mistakes you
don't need to watch those just ask me
i got plenty of those [__] stories
especially in the [__] snow
that's what was making me think about
all this that once the snow got added to
my [__] element
it was tough being a klepto because you
leave tracks it's tough
it's tough being a [__] klepto
because they got you at the [__]
tracks
i had to learn how to work around that
[__] so
i was a klepto full time until it
started snowing and then my roommate
brought it up to me he's like dog
they're going to catch you with the
[__] tracks with those [__] boots
you got to wear boots at people that are
very popular
you know so everybody had sorel's i
guess they call them
sorel's boots that's what they had so i
had to get sorels that were really
popular
to [__] shoplift you know but i i at
that time i had watched a movie called
the thief with james khan
i was doing all these little klepto
moves and i thought
it was time for me to pull the [__]
trigger
i felt it was time for me to go [__]
big time
so between us
i always told you i took classes and i
took residential wiring as an elective
i took residential wiring so i could
learn
how to break into a [__] house
makes sense to you now you think i took
residential wiring because i was crazy
about being an electrician
no i took residential wiring because it
would give me an intro
into wiring and then it just so happened
i got good at it
and i started working for an electrician
and while i was working
for the electrician i met another man
that today i actually think
he was in a witness relocation plan
today
he wasn't a new york guy not a mobster
guy
for some reason now today in hindsight
you know 2020 i think the guy was a
[__]
relocated witness he was a deadly killer
i did not know that he had a sweet
[__] wife
i basically lived over there it started
off with i forget his
and her name you know i love to reach
out to them now
and thank them for how they treated me
they didn't have kids
he was one of the top electricians at
the company
uh they assigned me to him after i
[__] [__] up the other guy
the other guy that we beat with the
stick down there and [__] carbondale
they assigned me to him
he taught me a lot about electricity but
i could tell one night we were having a
conversation he had a little wild slide
to him
so i started asking him about alarms
and he started teaching me about alarms
you know where to cut him this that how
to bypass him
you know he taught me little stuff we
actually did
two or three little jobs we didn't steal
nothing
just to learn how to bypass the alarm
you know
it was 83 it wasn't like
it wasn't nothing very eccentric nothing
like
lights or beams or there was no cameras
so
there was less to worry about it was
just a common
you know breakthrough the if you could
get through the alarm box and move
some wires you could open up a window
and get in there you know
i wasn't no high level [__] pink
panther
i don't want you to think that either
you know in my head
that's who i wanted to be you know i was
lifting weights
i was running everything i did
was to help me be a better thief this is
a very sad story to tell
but it's a very true story you know
so the big thing i was working up for
was a job i was gonna take down
around between christmas
and new year's eve i was gonna take down
i had already taken down a bunch of
places and i had already
raised the flag in snowmass village
now they were looking they couldn't put
their finger on who was doing it
so i cooled down for like two and a half
three weeks i cooled down
i left them completely in their tracks i
didn't know what the [__] to think
you know me dawg i always got three
things ahead of me so
i made a decision to go back to new
jersey february 1st of 84.
i had some money put away do you know
that you know i actually put away
good money not a million dollars not a
half a million dollars
not a quarter of a million dollars i
probably had a couple grand
i don't know eight nine grand i don't
know and in those days
that was good enough for me that was
good enough for anybody but it wasn't
good enough for the clipped on me
plus i had a block of hash i had a
couple ounces of [__] coke
i had a bag of [__] jewelry i didn't
have anything at my house
i was working on a construction project
a four-week project with this whole man
and he was redoing these five condos
so he told me that the third condo in
the middle
the people only come in july they don't
even come in the winter they don't like
skiing
they only came there for the tour of
france like the bike thing and some
balloon race or some [__]
so he told me he goes if you ever are in
a bind
go underneath and take the key out you
could they had food in there
the tv worked the [__] phone worked
so what i did was i didn't involve that
house because
if they came home then i would be stuck
they had a little ski closet outside
i didn't break the lock i just didn't i
made it so the lock couldn't close
and i would hide all my stuff in there
anything that i stole
coke cash that blocked the hash
anything i stole wouldn't be on me it
wouldn't be on their house
it would be in a general area where a
couple people had access to
the reason why if i ever got caught
going in there
my buddy did the maintenance for the
building and that's where he would put
his tools
there was just like a missing block all
the way in the end
that unless you put your finger in you
wouldn't be able to pull it out
i pulled it out and i hid my stuff back
then i put the block there
so i always had an excuse to be back in
there
it was where he hid like a couple
shovels some rakes
a couple hammers some nails [__] like
that that's what was in there
so i never had anything in my house plus
i had my jewelry tools in there
my jewelry tools my stealing tools in
there you know tools i needed to go and
plot pry bar
i had this [__] saw a handsaw that my
buddy had bent for me
a certain way so i could just slip it
into the door jambs
and go right through the door and just
push the door right open
i had everything i wasn't the i wasn't
the most high level thief in the world
but i had a heart you know what i'm
saying show me a thief with heart
and you're gonna find your sneakers are
missing that's all i got to say so
i [__] had it all planned out
i walked past this jewelry store
it's next to the [__] sandwich place
every time i go to the sandwich place i
would go to the sandwich
place at night to see what the jewelry
store guy would leave out
he got lazy you know how most i don't
know if you know this
most jewelry stores per their insurance
have to put
everything away in a safe at night and
lock up the safe
this guy was got half a drunk a half a
coke head
and there's times people would go up
there and see him and he would just lock
up and go out and leave
and go to aspen and leave everything out
in the glass so i was paying attention
to him
i would go up there every night just to
take a walk and see what nights he would
leave
things out and one night that he would
leave stuff out for sure
was always on sundays for some reason on
sundays especially during football
season
he would leave everything out so i said
you know what i made myself a promise
i'm not gonna break into anything no
more i'm just gonna do this one
[__] jewelry store so i got my buddy
from the
the electrician buddy his name was bob
that's what i just remember his name bob
robert
i got bob to go up there with me and get
a sandwich
and we ate the sandwich on the balcony
so we could dissect the alarm system
he told me right off the bat he goes
that type of alarm
is usually wired to a police station
this is not a good hit for you
i go listen by the time the wire hits
the police station
i could go in there and take
half that [__] that's in those
things and i'm not going to run towards
the cops
i'm gonna run away from the cops to the
condo i got hidden in that closet
i could just go up there lock my [__]
stuff up there and lock myself in the
apartment to the heat
cools off he goes you got a point i go
how much response time would i have
he goes well depending on what they're
doing i mean
you could see from the jewelry store you
could see
the mall and the police station was on
top of the mall
so i say it was maybe it was maybe a
six or seven mile walk maybe a four or
five minute drive
but if the cops are under the substation
like that towards the 82
i'm gonna see the lights coming up you
know
so he goes that's that's what it is he
goes for me
it's not worth it but if you feel
you could go in there and break the
glasses and take everything out
so i went up there he didn't have
cameras i would study
what i needed to bust the stuff to make
it more efficient
my plan was to cut the wire so that
would get deterred go into the back door
come in
pop the six locks and then go back with
a bag
and empty everything run out through the
front door
puts me through a path takes me to my
hidden condo
my little bat cave where i put on my
construction clothes
and walk back down the hill past the
cops like nothing happened
like i was just doing some work up there
for him
that was the plan on a [__] tuesday
and i was going to stick to it because
the following weekend was going to be
new years and then it was going to be
january there was going to be no [__]
money
and [__] aspen which is a lie there's
still money up there
but the big money is going to be
christmas [__] week
i want to do this one heist lay low all
of january
[__] with the head and then i'll go back
to new jersey in
february and i'll never don't don't that
it'll be an unsolved crime that was my
big [__] plan
so sure enough the week comes
when i'm gonna [__] rob the uh
jewelry store i'm ready to [__] go
tip top magoo
i take my [__] switch clothes i bring
them up to the house up in the daytime
i bring all my tools up in the house in
the daytime
and i'm ready to [__] go the only
problem i should have done was i should
have created a diversion
i should have lit something on fire or
blew up a [__] bond
or something that's why i [__] up but
everywhere else i was okay i had all my
bases covered
i went up there to check sure enough he
left with some chick
left all the diamond rings and bracelets
and
all the other knickknacks he had in the
glass
i'm ready to [__] go here we go
now like i said at this time i had
destroyed them all on christmas eve
so cops were on high end it even [__]
said it in the local snowmass paper
uh snowmass village mall terrorized on
christmas eve
i kicked down a few doors yeah i took
the guy's conga drum
i still think about the conga drum like
i have no class
whatsoever when it comes to being a
klepto i'm happy i can tell you people
these stories because i'm not i gotta
keep them in the closet
and they'll drive me [__] crazy so
the day comes it's sunday i'm gonna rob
this [__] i look out my window
and snowflakes this big are coming down
not this big this [__] big it is a
[__] utopia of snow
it is coming down like it's nobody's
[__] business
i put my boots on i put my little winter
clothing on
i take a little walk up there they're
open business as usual
people are going in there the mountain
is covered
every time i used to used to go to this
place called the stewpot it's still
there
they make the best [__] stew in the
world they used to make a burgundy beef
that would make your little [__]
pucker if you [__] tasted it just
[__] tremendous
so i went to the stupot that day and i'm
scoping out that place
and i'm watching people spending money
because i'm gonna
listen i don't know how much time i'm
gonna have that jewelry store
but i'm gonna take the jewelry and then
second i'm gonna take the [__] cash
okay that's that's the plan
that's the plan stan first the jewelry
then the cash hopefully he leaves the
cash and the [__]
uh the cash box whatever the [__] it's
called
the register come nine o'clock i look
out my window there's a foot and a half
of snow
and it's still coming down like [__]
jesus is making a comeback
do you understand me like the way i
don't know where you people live right
now
but the way it snows like four to six
inches
in ski season in aspen snowmass riverton
wyoming
it's 18 it's like a brushing people look
at 18 like huh
we got snow today no big [__] deal
where other people would
you know in colorado it snows a foot and
nothing
life goes on it snowed a foot and a half
here the
the mailman don't come [__] garbage
doesn't come
colorado it's no three feet it's
business as usual
you could set your time by the [__]
bus that thing is on time by the [__]
minute
anyway to make a long story short
there's a foot and a half of [__]
snow out there
he calls me up bobby's like you're not
doing it i'm going bro
it's going to happen tonight tonight's
tonight they're going to be stuck with a
car
accident or some drunk is going to go
off an embarkment
they're never going to hear their alarm
if there's even an alarm in the police
station
if there's even an alarm in the [__]
police station
they're not gonna [__] figure it out
okay
what am i gonna do [__] it
i'm from north bergen new jersey i got
balls of steel
i'm a dumb [__] so i go up there
i walk through the [__] snow
[__] two feet of [__] snow i'm
walking i'm getting tired
it's high altitude i'm huffing and
puffing i finally get up there there's
no shovelers there's nothing
it's just a couple lights on i [__]
go over to the [__] door i brought a
little [__] stool with me
i popped the stool i put it down i
snipped the red wire like he told me to
i [__] go around the [__] back i
try to [__] finagle the door
it won't [__] do it so i go around
the front
and i [__] stick the thing in and pop
the door opens up
i go in i go behind the back counter
and as i go behind the back counter to
start uh
sticking the [__]
pipe in there to [__] pop bust that
[__] lock
i see a red flash on the wall
and i go holy [__] i turn around
and sure enough there's two cop cars
coming up that [__] hill
two sobs they had sobs in stonemass
village
they're coming up this [__] hill my
heart's beating
listen i'm old school i got to take
something
i broke this i got to take some you
attack me with three people i gotta take
something an eye
a finger i gotta bite a finger i gotta
bite an ear i gotta stick my finger in
an eye
you know what i'm saying three people go
jump you you got to take something
something's going to go a hand an arm so
i got to take something
so i'm like getting i break a [__]
glass i can't break it
it's shatter [__] glass i turn around
again they're getting closer to me
i don't know what the [__] to do and
what do you think i did i chickened out
i ran out the front [__] door and i
ran
directly to the [__] condo house
okay now it's snowing
so [__] much that i could tell
that those footprints are gonna get
covered
within minutes so i'm not running like a
regular human being
i'm dragging my feet okay like i'm
roller skating
which is hell on the [__] cardio when
there's 18 inches of [__] snow i get
up to that [__] house
i [__] walk up and i walk up and down
all around the [__] condo
i walk 30 yards up i see the two cop
cars pull in
i see the guys pull out their cars i
could see him run up to the mall i'm
already gone
i'm 50 yards away watching them behind a
[__] tree
making snow tracks on purpose you know
i'm saying trying to throw them off
i finally go in i switched my sweatshirt
whatever thing i hit it onto the [__]
cat guy's couch
and then i went out and put the thing
locked the door hit the [__] key
and i put on like a sweatshirt like i
had been painting
you know what i'm saying like with a hat
and gloves and the whole thing
and you know me dawg i was always one
step ahead i wasn't like
i'm an idiot i'm not just a complete
[__] [__]
i [__] walk down the hill i actually
see the cops
and they see me and they're like how you
doing they're like have you seen
anything suspicious tonight i go no
i was up in the condo uh painting for
roy
everybody knew who he was and it would
be an alibi
even roy would say yeah yeah he was up
there he gets bored some nights and he
goes up then does trim for me
or whatever so i had that covered
so i'm like whoo i [__] walk home
it's like you know maybe a 10 minute
walk
i walk in my door i kick the [__]
door you know
i [__] uh take my boots off
i put him next to the door and
i'm watching [__] tv with my friend
my roommate my roommate goes what
happened
i go as a no go
and he goes all right what are you gonna
do next time i go
[__] i really wanted that jewelry you
know
i really wanted that [__] money
and next thing you know [__] there's
a knock on the door
and i open the door and it's three
sheriffs
they're like can we have a word we get
my cat come on in
and they're like uh and i go to one
sheriff i don't met
and he goes uh where were you
tonight when we saw you
and i know i was uh
i was at the house painting you know
just
i was bored i didn't want to watch the
playoffs were done i think it was the
nfl playoffs or something
and here's the story i said the story
wrong
the cop that i saw didn't come to the
house
it was he was with two other cops
and then three other cops came to my
house
okay so they knocked on my door
and they asked me where i was and i told
him my gosh
what's up but uh they go did you go out
tonight i go yeah i was up at
roy's property painting the trimming i
go in fact i saw
the guys i'm gonna walk back down here
and then like that's great no
but uh what time
was this or something they asked me some
type of question
and i go this must have been like two
hours ago
i threw him off on the tie and the one
cop
looked down and the boots were right
there and with the melting
and he goes this doesn't look like a
boot
that's been here for two hours
this boot would have been a lot more
melted
and i was like out of words they had me
i'm like what is this all about
and they're like well somebody tried to
break into the
village jewelry store and we took a
print
off from the back door and when the guy
got away
he ran into the mountains so we lost him
but we picked up this print in the
beginning of
the driveway and we measured it
it's a size 11 and
we hope your boot is not a size 11.
and it was a size 11. and i'm like what
are you [__] saying that i robbed the
[__] jewelry store
do you not see the [__] paint on my
hands what do you think i'm stupid
i put paint on my hands i put it on my
face and [__]
i just go i just robbed it and that's
what threw them off
see that was my you know an attorney's
job is to prove
through a reasonable doubt my [__]
job was to just lift that [__] rock
they had their handcuffs dog they had
their [__] handcuffs out
and i was like whoa what are you talking
about
i did this i did this i just painted
get roy on the phone you know we didn't
have a phone so they had to go next door
and call roy
and roy goes yeah he works for me does
he usually work
sunday nights at eight o'clock and then
like there's one day i found them in
there
on monday at four in the morning that
kid has sleep problems or whatever
so the guy was like okay but uh
stick around we're gonna come right back
and question you
and all this [__] and i'm like okay see
you
and they this had to be december 28th
maybe 29th and i left that all i had to
hold on to is february 1st
i did not [__] i did not jaywalk
until february [__] first so for me
to get out of there so
the lesson learned today here that and
that was basically
well it depends how you look at it
it depends how you look at it that
basically woke like i felt bad for my
roommate
because my roommate was also from north
bergen
he was a great guy and i didn't want him
ridiculed
like i told you guys a long time ago i'm
not the type of guy
that likes taking people into dark
alleys if i like doing [__] i like doing
[__] alone
so nobody else gets in trouble i don't
need a [__] partner if you listen to
any of those stories
there was never really a partner i did
all those things alone because
i didn't want to humiliate somebody else
and i didn't want to put
anybody up i had friends that went on a
couple eyes with me and stuff like that
as a try you know but that's not what i
wanted for them
and i just it wasn't it wasn't for me
you know when when jimmy burke was one
of my best friends in life
god rest his soul and when those cops
knocked in the door
that was not his world if it was his
world i wouldn't have given a [__]
but it was in this [__] world so you
know those cops were in that apartment
for like 35 minutes
and every time i looked at him his face
was getting redder and redder
i felt horrible for him that wasn't his
[__] world
so you know it's just to show you that
life's a [__] sometimes
i knew how to be a [__] burglar
without the snow
with the snow i almost [__] got
caught there ain't a point to this story
today
i just wanted to tell you this story to
get it out of the way because it just
reminded me
of the [__] snow and what i went
through you guys have no idea
what i went through being a burglar with
the [__] snow
it was a complete nightmare and someday
after i write my first book i'll write a
third or fourth book blunders in the
snow
of me robbing things and the snow being
a [__] nightmare
i remember one time i robbed this dude's
house and what i would do is whenever i
rob somebody's house in creekside
the first thing i would do is i would
open up the back door
so i would see how to exit i would have
an
additional exit so i [__] put the
thing in the door
i would open the door and then i'd run
to the back door
and it was a sliding glass door this is
windows here
this was a sliding glass door i would
open up the sliding glass door
and open it in case i had to ram run out
of there
and in case somebody was coming into the
front door one night i heard a car pull
up
and i heard it because it was like uh
it was like that wood that they use on
kids playgrounds
like that chunk wood to get to the front
door and then you had
stairs it looked like kids playground i
don't know why
i heard a guy walking through that one
night and i'm like holy [__]
so i started running towards the door
and as i opened up the curtain
and i ran towards the door i realized i
had opened the door but i left the
screen on
and i'll never forget [__] going
through the screen
and the screen didn't break the screen i
didn't go through the screen i hit the
screen
and the screen went down with me boom
like the bottom of a grinder
and all the snow popped up on top of me
and i [__] got up and ran it wasn't
even the guy who lived in the [__]
apartment
there was some guy who lived in another
[__] two apartments over there
dog i got tons of blunder [__]
thievery stories
like i told you guys i i don't come on
here
to tell you how smart i am or how much
of a whiz kid i am or whatever
i come on here to tell you the truth i'm
a [__] half a [__]
and if that story don't prove it i don't
know what does
he told me 18 times that that [__]
thing was wired to the police station
i'm like this guy he's not that smart
no it's not that [__] wire
what the [__] do i know another fun
filled
[__] story with your uncle joey today
i just wanted to check it on you again
i am very sorry about bringing you the
podcast on a [__] thursday
i know that it's in your rotation of the
wednesday but hey man
we got foots of snow feats of [__]
snow i don't know how to [__] say it
we got tons of snow [__] everywhere
and i figured i put the album of the
week up on patreon
to give you something great album
[__] santana abraxas
so i took a on patreon the other guys
you guys have a podcast
to listen to or whatnot i felt bad for
you though it's not something i like
doing but we had to do what was best for
both of us
mikey has kids i have kids i didn't want
mike driving
and [__] two feet of snow and [__]
hitting some [__] guy with a
ghost slow sign you ever see those guys
you never see him till you're right
there
it's like a guy on a bike when you're
about to make the right and he's
standing at you like what the [__] you
been
i've been here for 10 minutes i haven't
seen you now i'm about to make the right
night you want to go straight [__]
they drive you [__] crazy it's tough
to even drive anymore
anyway i love you [__] it's
been a great week
uh i had a rough day yesterday also
kind of in a way i'm happy i kind of
didn't do the podcast yesterday
not that i had a rough day i didn't i
don't want you guys to think i had a
rough day i was crying or anything like
that
yesterday was my daughter's 31st
birthday
i haven't seen my daughter
and god knows how [__] long right now
right now
i can't even call him my daughter i have
to call him my aunt's daughter
but it's funny how i thought about her a
lot yesterday
um you know i have no
[Music]
gripes at her i'm not mad at her
she did what she had to do and i created
my own situation a lot of men
a lot of women a lot of people will
never tell you this
it's always something happened to them
or
somebody did something to them in this
situation
i brought it upon myself you know i
acted a certain way
i acted like a [__] jerk off i'm not
gonna lie to you
i went into full joe diaz
[__] mode when i was her father
never anything towards her it was the
war
that me her mother and her stepfather
and
today i had justifications for some of
my arguments
and for some of the other arguments i
was just
arguing to be an [__] uh
you know out of the 100 things i tell
you about this situation
50 of them are true
50 of it are probably how i felt at the
time
or how i looked at it or how i saw it at
the time
you know somebody asked me the other day
why i felt the way i did
she moved my child into another man's
house
without even telling me without even
asking me
you know i don't know about you or where
you came from
in a neighborhood where i live now if
you were to do that to me
and i shot you in the [__] head and i
called the cops i think the cops would
understand
you know she did something to me that
shouldn't have been done but there's
another side to that story
i should have been more of a [__] man
and she wouldn't have done that
right or wrong you know by me acting
like an immature [__] punk that i was
i drove her and my daughter into another
man's arms
i drove her into another man's arms my
daughter had nothing to do with it
she was a victim of circumstances but uh
it is what it is you know it was my
behavior
uh it was her behavior also
it takes two to tango but uh
i want to apologize to her if any of her
friends
watch this podcast or listen or whatever
i just want to wish her a happy belated
birthday
i still love you to death it's funny
when i go at night
and kiss my daughter like i kiss my my
daughter comes out the living room and
gives me a kiss
and then i go in there about 9 25
and give her another kiss while she's
awake and then i go back in there
by 11 and i give her another kiss while
she's sleeping
and i grab her foot to see how big her
feet are getting
and it's so weird how the last time i go
in there around 11 right before miami
vice
i always go what [__] life if i am i
living and i'm living in a twilight zone
i'm living in a twilight zone because i
had a daughter
she was taken from me and i'm right back
where i started from with another
daughter
who's eight years old who now i
treat and i act around her and how a man
should act this is how a man should act
i act around her this way i act around
my wife that way
and that's why we've been here 20 years
so in a way
i lost a daughter but i learned how to
live a new life
and i made a new life and i have a new
life and i have a life that's [__]
working
you know that's the bottom line whatever
the [__] you want to say
it's working me my little reefer my
little bong hits
my couple edibles my [__] up knee with
the stitches
my [__] eyebrows my gray hair
it's working so uh i just want to wish
her
a happy belated i want to wish her the
best future she has coming to her
i am not angry at her whatsoever i'm not
angry or whatsoever
you have to earn your right to be a
father
i never earned the right to be a father
with her i earned my right to be a
father with mercy
and i feel comfortable with that and i'm
good with that and i can live with that
so if you ever went through what i went
through with a child
make amends with yourself you feel a lot
better i feel great
when i used to talk about this subject
10 years ago on the podcast
it was a little uncomfortable today i
have a daughter
i'm living to the twilight zone it's
like nothing ever happened i'm right
back to where i started again
and then some so i have nothing to
complain about
i don't look i don't [__] about the
[__] i don't have
i i i'm thankful and i'm grateful
for this [__] i do have and i leave it
at that and with that
that's another fun-filled [__]
podcast don't forget tonight
lake is [__] denver philly phoenix
take a look at those lines philly
portland
that's for you with draftkings don't
forget the super bowl this weekend
don't forget draftkings and please don't
forget the relief band
it's [__] great i know all your
parents the reason
let me tell you something about relief
man before i close on this
[__] i get this in the mail
my agent usually calls me and she says
hey there's a company that's interested
in being on your podcast
do you want to try that product out i
say yes or no
it's not gonna work i have a a chart of
things that you guys are interested in
that you're really interested in
i wouldn't try to sell you something
you're not interested in i wouldn't even
try to bring light to it
she didn't tell me with this i get this
in the mail
when you get this in the mail this
relief ban
it talks about you know clinically
proven
and uh wonder i gotta put my glasses on
i'm sorry [__]
it's motion sickness morning sickness
chemotherapy post-operative
physician diagnosed migraines anxiety
and hangovers well i had two of those
i have post-operative and anxiety okay
so
i looked at it and i go hmm i wonder who
sent me this i called bob lalingus
i called everybody who sends me gifts
like off-color gifts
i have like 10 of you [__] that
know how to send me gifts you send me
the best gifts
and the [__] that i can never find on my
own
i call bob i called my [__] cousin
i called a friend of mine in florida he
sends me books
i called a friend of mine and nobody
sent me this
i called my acupuncturist nobody [__]
okay i go i asked my doctor when i went
to surgery i go did you [__] send me
this one she goes now
who the [__] sent me this goddamn watch
this week she calls me she's like oh
what did you think of the watch
i go what [__] watch the movement
watch i loved it she goes no
the relief band bandwatch i go did you
send me that she goes yeah
holy [__] i've been banging my head for
five [__] weeks
trying to find out who the [__] sent me
the relief band
and it was you but you know what it
works it's kept me together
those [__] oxycodones make you
nauseated as [__]
i [__] got sick two times in a drive
back from pt
i got sick one morning in here and ever
since that time i've been wearing that
watch
so if you suffer from nausea this is the
watch for you
and beside that that's it that's it
we're good to go we had a great week
i'm sorry the podcast was late but we're
here
we're queer and that's all that [__]
matters all right
do not forget this weekend super bowl me
i think i'm gonna go with the totals
how's that
i love brady too much he's getting three
points
uh mahone's a great [__] quarterback
i don't know what the [__] he's gonna do
i don't you know i don't know so let's
just play the totals
enjoy the game and have a great weekend
guys remember what i told you
about draftkings if you got a problem
take it somewhere else you don't need to
be gambling go [__]
take care of your problems and without
further ado i love you [__]
have a great weekend stay black
see you monday here's for a word
from my sponsors
that wasn't a fart that was the chat
anyway i want to thank you [__]
for listening today it's a beautiful
thursday
sorry we were late with the podcast you
know
mike lives the distance from here that
the snow was too crazy you know what
and it worked out a lot better on a
thursday anyway you're having a better
time but before i get out of here
let's talk about what's happening this
weekend you know what's happening this
weekend
mucho [__] dinero that's what's
happening this weekend
and for you [__] who never saw
sesame street that means a lot of money
to be made
what's coming up it's the [__] super
bowl the 55th super bowl
is here this sunday live from tampa
the buccaneers with tom brady versus the
chiefs with the [__] quarterback
that's a whiz kid
right now the party starts at draftkings
it's super bowl weekend
it's thursday this party starts right
now at [__] draftkings
to celebrate the football finale
draftking sportsbook
is doubling your money if a touchdown is
scored in a big game
a single touchdown that's all it takes
that's right
it only takes one touchdown to be scored
sunday night
and boom your money is double sounds
like a no-brainer right
a single touchdown and you double your
dope that's it
if you've been waiting all year on the
sidelines that's it this is the last
[__] train out that's it
that's it no more [__] around you got
to jump on this [__] deal today
one touchdown is scored and you win
money and you're sitting there thinking
like [__] uh you know
like you're a [__] philosopher go
[__] yourself download the draftking
sports book app
now right now use promo code joey
and get a shot at doubling your money if
a touchdown is scored
on sunday's game and don't forget about
draftkings big game prediction challenge
with up to 55 million dollars in total
prizes up for grabs
and instant prizes for everybody who
enters the contest
that's [__] fun you want to have fun
that's [__] fun
draftkings has paid out over seven
billion dollars
since 2012 that's fun and you could be
on the other side of that you could be
picking up that [__] envelope
so download the draftking sportsbook app
today right now
use promo code joey and get a shot at
doubling your money
during sunday night's [__] super bowl
only a draftking sports book
and here's the part the lawyers make me
say you got to be 21 or older
new jersey indiana colorado only
restrictions apply
see draftkings.com prediction
challenge dfs for details
now if you have a gaming problem you
gotta
you gotta stop that's a good thing about
draftkings you can't gamble over your
head
call one eight hundred gambler or an
indiana one eight hundred nine with it
or in colorado one eight 1-800-522-4700
you ain't got no problems and you're
showing up correct and you want to make
some [__] cash this weekend
whether it be fantasy over and under
special picks
challenges draftking sportsbook is the
app for you
download it now and press encode joey
the joint is also brought to you by
relief band
listen do you know a third of americans
suffer from nausea
yeah take a look at my face it's
nauseating that's what i'm talking about
you don't need this in your life you
understand me that's why i'm excited
about our new partner relief band i'm
wearing it right now i've had it on for
four weeks
relief ban is the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband that has been
clinically
proven to relieve and prevent nausea and
vomiting
the product is 100 drug free so it
doesn't make you drowsy that has zero
side effects
you know it's not what you ever watch a
commercial this has a side effect
you might want to gamble you might want
to kill yourself nothing like that here
okay
this blocks a signal from your brain
send it to your stomach
telling you that you're sick that's how
it works it simulates a nerve in the
wrist
that travels to the part of the brain
that controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach it's
[__] science relief ban is the only
over-the-counter
wearable band that has been used in
hospitals and oncology clinics to treat
nausea and vomiting all these have a
sick mother
a sick dad a sick aunt a sick
grandmother
a sick uncle they have nausea this is a
great gift for valentine's day
whatever i don't care help him out this
has helped me out tremendously i charge
it at night when i'm sleeping
i wake up in the morning i throw it on
my wrist i give it a breather in the
afternoon if i take a nap i charge it
again
it is on my wrist all day you understand
me
it's beautiful you go like this
you control the how strong you want the
power on it
if you want the power to be boom
boom there you have it there you have it
so do yourself a favor
ensure nausea is never the reason to
miss out on life's important moments
right now relief ban has a special offer
for all uncle joey's joint listeners if
you go to reliefband.com
and use promo code joey listen to this
20 off free shipping and a no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee
did you hear me 20 off free shipping
and a no questions asked 30 day
money-back guarantee
so head on over to relief ban
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use promo code joey
for 20 off and get some relief
i want to thank relief band i want to
thank draftkings
i want to thank annette cbd lion i want
to thank all you guys
for being part of the family and for
listening
i want to thank uh who else was there
this week
i want to thank mbmt watchers who had
our back this week
please support these companies you know
everything is done over the mail
whatever
but don't forget what i told you about
draftkings especially tonight with the
lakers denver
and you got a great game with portland
philly take a look at the line
and make sure you get it on the super
bowl that's it and that's that i love
you [__] have a great weekend
sorry about the podcast coming on
thursday but we showed up no matter what
we delivered the goods
enjoy love you [__]
stay black
so
you